all right new video going 15 minute game
playing against the American here move
that piece okay going for sloth here see
what what line is coming up coming up
with him takes on e 60 a 6 or something
else okay should G for some an unusual
move
yeah 95 looks like the normal reaction
here trying to win a temple as he most
likely needs to move the bishop again
ok
usually the problem with this kind of
only bishop moves here in the Slav is
some at least a white hasn't played
slowly like III or something it's um
it's a combination of taking on d5 at 23
on queen bee three I think he can play
Queen B 6 okay but that take here it
takes with the poor now queen bee three
should be a rather strong okay to come
with the night
Oh interesting all kinds of tactics are
maybe possible here already moved like
let's say a form takes on c3 queen bee
three stuff like this medicine is
interesting I have the maître threat on
f7 but I think you can take on d4 in
this line could also go queen bee three
right now
hmm how interesting interesting
possibilities also if for takes on c3 bc
Bishop b4 queen bee three is also
interesting threatening f7 and b7
this looks good really a queen bee three
not sure what he's doing then right
well okay he needs to take on t3 now
shouldn't be much choice at this point
yep if it takes e4 now queen bee three
if he goes bishop d firefighter captured
be seven and this is just winning hey
does hanging and he cannot protect it c5
I played should be five check and he
loses all his pieces it's made you
nothing um let's say queen d 50 Bishop
before queen bee three queen d 5 I just
have okay I can take me seven now but I
can also play Bishop f4 take f7 so yeah
not sure I don't think he has a move if
it takes only form of course you can can
do some yeah move like Bishop g6 or bit
should be six or something well white
just has a huge um space advantage and
of course our grade center
yeah which is somewhat the logical
consequence of moving the pieces so
often okay queen bee three what what's
now when you six I grabbed be seven and
eight is gone if he goes Bishop Knight
to d7 then I can just capture the night
and he cannot recapture onda seven
because Luke a it is hanging so i don't
really am don't really see a defense
here that doesn't lose its lots of
material maybe you can try to get away
with just being an exchange down this is
possible like Bishop g5 Queen B 7 + f6
very ugly but maybe a possible if I
would then retreat the night you can go
97 someone slightly am I need to grab
this rook now done on and on and on aid
and then I'm just am an exchange up
maybe this is so the relatively best
defense okay some other tries could play
3 p-6 can we an f7 King d8 doesn't
inspire much confidence yeah I think
Bishop d5 there's nothing else and then
f6 trying to be just an exchange down
this might be a at least if I be able to
continue then uh-huh
okay nothing else and now just 97 does
he have some some so some huge idea here
Queen a five but I can just play Bishop
d2 and I'm p sub community seven just a
a task on the night on this have not so
covers the be eight square for the rook
so not sure don't see em both just a
piece
yep it's a game over basically
alright so watch try to to execute this
listener in a convincing fashion he's
not really threatening anything now at
the moment especially by by threatening
I mean castling I need to I'd like to
keep the king and the center of course i
could play em could play a silly move
like Bishop g5 here but I'm not sure
might just take and sacrifice both rooks
and try for some crazy counter-attack
most likely it's not working but not
sure I want to check this
yeah I'd like to really force a win
quickly here don't see it though
yeah there's no way to to really finish
this off immediately don't think so all
right let's retreat the night
ok what's the cleanest way here
yeah if I developed my bishop you might
just take g 2 i'm not sure if i won dad
it's no big deal really I have bishop
age six and stuff like this ok come on
just develop him
and we need five maybe queen 85 is a
problem here
hmm now will I can just cancel yeah i
thought i could just castle or queen bee
three queen bee three rook rook be aids
maybe maybe possibility then nights you
form takes Knight a5 yeah should win or
just screen be too
if I castle will create I can go between
a 623 I can play we should be three okay
come on just cancer here you might get
get a pawn or something but it's not a
big deal my hope is up
knight c6 sides too far too complicated
calculating this stuff Bishop here so
I've got my Miami development completed
now I'm sure there was some more
convincing way to to convert this but
some still pretty much enough
yeah threatening 97 now so maybe you
just need to take this for you to take
the night mm-hmm okay what exactly is
the point 97 what what's what's
happening with some trick or what don't
see anything
yeah this is just a rook was a piece up
before and now grabbing another exchange
means next to rook
yeah not much not much to to commend you
he's just ticking let's the clock tick
down and trying to find some way to UM
to save here but it's just it just far
more materials getting lost queer look
to be too okay okay Brooke is a rock
what now
mmm all kinds of most possible okay get
the Queen bag
if he goes to before now i can play
Bishop c1 trapping another look isn't
this another look okay can take on
YouTube Bishop c4 but exchanges don't
exactly help here
didn't you say you can just capture okay
all right now I know it doesn't matter
really should i come on let's exchange
more pieces even
yeah it was a bit silly but it's an
extra rope after all what about Bishop a
three we should be three should exchange
even more if he captures twice ever okay
one at the end getting a bishop back
here
he might even continue this one it
should be two tags Bishop takes our okay
six grabs another pawn him
I'm not quite sure what the point is
with four minutes left and root down
yeah okay
I just put put those pieces the rukon on
a light square to make sure you can
never take it so the useful device of
your low on time to put the pieces on
the other color so the bishop can never
rest them because I've got four minutes
left so no big deal but it's still
useful trick
yeah this was designed to get to f7 now
you will lose some even more material
okay okay this is all nicely protected
and I can just grab the f porn with the
King and then finish this off with a
mating attack
yeah of course I can i can try to mate
with rook night a rogue patient and king
or just get age six would also win
rather easily
sure
woof g7 maybe Luke g8 threatened Bishop
hanging not even any far-fetched stay
matrix so it's completely useless to
continue this black resigned all right
yeah what's useful to remember what this
game is the opening here he went for for
this early Bishop we should move here
and this is it's just a bad move
sometimes you manage to get out your
Bishop erm Slav like this but usually y
term needs to have made some kind of
concession let's say in this position
here if white goes III you can play
Bishop g4 but not if white has increased
the pressure on d5 already then both
Bishop f5 and Bishop g4 are not so great
but Bishop g4 think it says even worse
than Bishop f5 because it's just
basically grabs the tempo and yeah this
is already terrible it needs to move the
bishop again this just loses so it's a
yeah
yeah this is just just dead loss he
needs to yeah move the bishop again to
ya g six maybe and then I have more than
one interesting continuation I can just
play queen bee three again or we should
see four maybe even moves like f for
each form because the the bishop really
is a bit of trouble I have sorry still
somewhat sleepy here yeah thanks for
watching and see you soon with new
videos